dans l'actualité ce soir les grèves et
les manifestations s'amplifient dans le
monde contre la flambée du pétrole
camionneurs à londres étudiant en
indonésie pêcheurs à madrid des pêcheurs
qui durcissent encore le mouvement en
france face aux conflits nicolas sarkozy
annonce des mesures d'urgence l'état
redistribuera les surplus de tva
encaissée sur l'essence
la prime à la cuve passera de 150 à 200
euros la région parisienne renoue avec
les gratte ciels l'architecte jean
nouvel a été choisi pour bâtir une
prochaine tour à la défense près de
paris 301 m elle abritera des bureaux et
des logements fin d'audience au procès
fourniret lé jury s'est retiré pour
délibérer après les plaidoiries
commander fanton un homme qui se juge
lui-même indéfendable éléments de
réponse dans un instant aux flyers en
chine un voeu répliques du séisme ont
détruit quatre cent mille maisons et
fait 63 blessés les autorités ont
commencé à drainer les lacs formés ces
derniers jours
enfin entre les gouttes et dans la
douleur amélie mauresmo passe le 1er
tour à roland garros ce soir gros plan
sur les prix des champions certains sont
repérés dès l'âge de 4 ou 5 ans bonsoir
et bienvenue à tous et bien une nouvelle
donne pour l'économie mondiale qui est
en train qui est en train de provoquer
l'envolée du prix du pétrole
c'était à prévoir chauffeur marins ou
même tout simplement étudiants un peu
partout sur la planète de l'asie à
l'europe une flambée de mécontentement
se fait sentir
alors qu'en france je vous le disais le
conflit des pêcheurs se durcit encore et
que de nouvelles catégories se font
entendre
cindy woodhouse un long cortège de poids
lourds paralysent la circulation sur
cette route menant au centre de londres
environ 300 camions entraient dans la
capitale en milieu de journée
et pour mieux se faire entendre ces
manifestants klaxons contre le prix
élevé des carburants
on est très en colère aucune mesure
n'était prise rien n'a été décidé pour
nous aider alors on va retourner voir le
premier ministre gordon brown et son
gouvernement pour leur dire que nous
avons un problème est que si nous avons
un problème aussi longtemps en indonésie
les étudiants protestent aussi dans
l'archipel les manifestations se
multiplient depuis que le gouvernement a
augmenté d'environ 30 % le prix des
carburants on veut faire pression sur le
gouvernement et le président pour qu'il
renonce à cette hausse
parce que cela rend encore plus
difficile aux conditions de vie au
portugal en espagne
certains pêcheurs sont déjà en grève
comme ici à barcelone
mais le principal syndicat a lancé un
appel à une grève illimitée à partir de
vendredi
les marins espagnols réclament des
mesures d'urgence comparable aux aides
annoncées par le gouvernement français
et si les fakirs et s'ils nous disent
aussi avec le gouvernement à fos sur mer
les pêcheurs ont bloqué ce matin l'accès
au port pétrolier
s'en est suivi en face à face tendu
révélateur d'une grogne qui demeurent
les mesures du gouvernement n'ont
semble-t-il pas apaisé les pêcheurs ont
et révolte aussi des agriculteurs des
ambulanciers qui ont manifesté ici et là
la remise en cause touche aussi bien sur
les chauffeurs routiers français qui
tentent de faire face
voici l'exemple d'une entreprise
alsacienne qui compte 450 camions là-bas
des primes sont attribués pour
encourager la conduite économique
stéphanie la fuente jean-pierre pasteur
chaque mois ce chauffeur routier
parcours 12000 km et son poids lourds
consomme trois mille huit cents litre de
gazole avec une moyenne de 32 litres aux
100 km il fait partie des bons élèves de
sa société car dans cette entreprise
alsacienne une fois par an les
conducteurs suivent une formation pour
rouler économique pour économiser 2 à 3
litres
en fonction d'un ensemble qui est bien
beau jeu et chaque ralentissement fort
chaque remise en allure importante
génère la consommation donc prévoir tout
simplement ne pas ne pas se faire
surprendre c'est la première chose
puisque leurs conseillers que tous les
maux avec notre fiche de paye on a nos
de suivi de consommation la consommation
n'a fait dans le beau avec une prime
suivant la consommation qu'on fait cette
prime est reversée en chèques carburant
à usage privé en motivant ses chauffeurs
entreprises gagnent environ 4 litres
pour 100 kilomètres parcourus une goutte
d'économie car avec 450 véhicules
la facture en gazole s'élève à un
million neuf cent mille euros par mois
c'est 30 % de plus que l'an passé
aujourd'hui on est dos au mur parce que
au niveau des économies ça fait des
années qu'on a on essaye par tous les
moyens de réduire la consommation
on y est arrivés on y arrive depuis
quelques années mais la maintenance est
pratiquement finie on peut plus
économiser plus le gazole et le premier
poste de dépense pour les transporteurs
qui attendent désormais un geste du
gouvernement sans quoi ils pourraient
être les prochains manifester leur
mécontentement
alors que faire précisément face au
pétrole cher
ça ne va pas s'arranger a reconnu
nicolas sarkozy ce matin le président de
la république qui a proposé une aide
d'urgence basée sur la tva on va y venir
dans un instant d'abord très matinale
c'est au marché de rungis qu'il avait
choisi de se rendre comme lors de sa
campagne
alexandre kara josé boulesteix c'est la
photo du jour de l'album élyséen main
dans la main régis nicolas et carla
sarkozy jours
à l'extérieur quelques travailleurs
sans-papiers manifestent vite évacué par
les forces de l'ordre du personnel qui
cède aujourd'hui enfin parce que 2
heures du matin serait ce qu'une heure
du matin déjà cela ils ont le goût de
l'effort
c'est sympathique comme cette france qui
se lève tôt
celle qui a fait le succès de nicolas
sarkozy pendant la campagne j'ai voulu
montrer que le président de la
république il était là aussi pour ceux
qui cassent pas les abribus qui demande
pas de subventions et petits pourtant la
vie difficile
j'ai voulu mettre sous le projecteur
cette france qui travaillent tôt
mais le sien
pas mieux pour son image
une arnaque
habimana viande et le fromage quand
vient le tour des poissonniers ça sera
peut-être gentil cheval environ c'est
comme vous souhaitez
mais vous sauter le café la halle et
finalement ce sera le café les mareyeurs
ne verront pas nicolas sarkozy
déception sera quand même voulu la peine
qu'ils se déplacent sans même pouvoir
est pressé m
sur l'intérêt centraux et donc 6h30 la
tournée s'achève au pavillon des fleuves
fait plus chaud dehors
treize mois après son élection nicolas
sarkozy a toujours le même goût pour la
campagne et je vous le disais donc sitôt
rentrée nicolas sarkozy répondant à nos
confrères d'rtl a donc proposé une aide
d'urgence pour aider les français les
plus touchés par l'augmentation des prix
du carburant
l'état va redistribuer les surplus de
tva encaissée grâce à cette augmentation
explication romain mais si nicolas
sarkozy s'attaque au prix du carburant à
la pompe son arme rendre les surplus de
tva aux français
le président estime cette manne entre
150 et 170 millions d'euros par
trimestre soit plus de 600 millions par
an explications pour un litre d'essence
à 55 centimes hors taxes il faut
rajouter la taxe sur les produits
pétroliers toujours fixe 61 centimes
d'euro puis la tva 22 centimes quand le
prix hors taxes augmentent de 10
centimes la tei pp reste fixe mais la
recette de tva augmente mécaniquement 24
centimes puisqu'elle est proportionnelle
au coût de l'essence
c'est ce surplus de tva que nicolas
sarkozy souhaite consacrer à un fonds
pour aider les français les plus touchés
par la hausse du prix du pétrole
l'idée n'est pas nouvelle en 2004 le
ministre de l'économie sarkozy faisait
la même annonce au 1er janvier le
gouvernement redonnera sous forme de
diminution de la fiscalité sur le
pétrole
les excédents de recettes que nous avons
engagé en 2004
problème l'état ne gagne pas forcément
d'argent quand le prix de l'essence
augmente car dans le même temps la
consommation diminue et avec elles
certaines recettes fiscales ainsi au
premier trimestre la tva pétrole a
rapporté 170 millions d'euros de plus
que prévu mais les recettes de tp pl ont
baissé de 100 millions le surplus global
n'est donc que de 70 millions d'euros
une goutte d'eau
dans un litre d'essence autre solution
beaucoup plus radicale proposée par
nicolas sarkozy plafonner les recettes
de tva au delà d'un certain niveau et ce
dans tous les pays de l'union européenne
et c'est sur ce point qu'on s'arrête un
instant plafonner la tva sur les
carburants pour rendre les sens moins
cher est ce une proposition qui retient
l'attention à bruxelles bruxelles qui
doit bien sûr donner son avis et plus
que cela même bonsoir françois
beaudonnet vous êtes notre correspondant
là bas apparemment il ya de la surprise
et du scepticisme
oui bonsoir david effectivement cette
proposition en tout cas cette idée de
nicolas sarkozy surprend tout le monde
ici à bruxelles
alors pour deux raisons d'abord parce
que pour modifier un taux de tva et bien
il faut l'unanimité des 27 pays de
l'union européenne d'ailleurs nicolas
sarkozy l'a reconnu ce matin donc c'est
très compliqué c'est très long et ça
pourrait durer dans le meilleur des cas
plusieurs années deuxième motif de
surprise ici à bruxelles c'est que bret
baisser les prix des carburants il ya
c'est repoussé d'autant l'utilisation
des énergies renouvelables or vous le
savez le protection de l'environnement
c'est l'un des dossiers phares de
bruxelles et c'est également l'une des
priorités de la future présidence
française donc ce qu'a voulu faire
nicolas sarkozy vraisemblablement ce
matin c'est ce qu'il fait maintenant
bien souvent sur le plan européen c'est
à dire mettre les pieds dans le plat
pour ouvrir le débat pour forcer nos
partenaires européens à entrer dans ce
débat et ça peut marcher parce qu'on l'a
vu toute l'europe a très peur de ce prix
du pétrole qui augmentent mais en tout
cas ça ne se jouera sûrement pas sur la
tv merci françois réactions à gauche de
ségolène royal elle se dit échaudé par
les annonces de nicolas sarkozy tant
qu'elles sont verbal j'attends de voir
fin de citation deux informations encore
à retenir de cette intervention sus du
chef de l'état il exclut toute
augmentation de la redevance pour
compenser la suppression de la publicité
sur l'audiovisuel public et il annonce
des états généraux cet automne pour la
presse en difficulté l'économie encore
avec cette enquête annuelle de
l'expansion qui montre vous allez le
voir que les problèmes de pouvoir
d'achat ne concerne pas tout le monde
les revenus des patrons du cac 40 ont
bondi de 58 % l'an dernier les salaires
de base sont restés modérés
ce sont les bonus et les stock options
qui font la différence sophie brune
burning
la patronne des patrons applaudi tel ses
homologues pour leur très forte
rémunération l'an dernier le revenu
moyen des dirigeants du cac 40 a bondi
de 58%
un chiffre obtenu en additionnant toutes
les composantes de leurs revenus
le salaire fixe le bonus liés aux
résultats les gains réalisés grâce au
stock options les dividendes versés au
titre des actions ainsi que les jetons
de présence au conseil d'administration
numéro un du classement pierre verluca
le patron de vallourec
cet inconnu du grand public dirige le
leader mondial des tubes en acier sans
soudure
il a empoché plus de 18 millions d'euros
soit une augmentation de 2300 12%
mais ce n'est pas son salaire qui
explique la progression son cours de
bourse
vallourec est liée à l'évolution du
secteur pétrolier dont le cours de
bourse a augmenté de manière
vertigineuse et ils visent des biens
tout simplement il a vendu ses stock
options quai qui ont été données à des
cours très bas
il les a vendus à un cours très haut et
bien fatalement ça fait une plus value
qui atteint des sommets 17 millions
d'euros
deuxième du classement gérard mestrallet
le président de suez avec 15 millions et
demi d'euros une augmentation de 300 64%
lille a aussi aux stock options
xavier huillard le nouveau président de
vinci à lui gagné plus de 13 millions
d'euros soit 552 pour son de mieux que
l'an passé
en 2007 le salaire fixe des grands
patrons n'a progressé que de 4% une
hausse raisonnable mais il semble qu'il
se soit largement rattrapé avec leurs
gains en bourse
la région parisienne renoue avec les
gratte ciel je vous le disais c'est
l'architecte jean nouvel qui a été
choisi pour bâtir une prochaine tour à
la défense près de paris 301 mètres de
haut avec ce projet la france s'inscrit
dans le mouvement de gigantisme qui a
saisi les capitales du monde daniel
wolfromm sylvain aubin si tout va comme
prévu ce sera cela dans cinq à dix ans
le nouveau visage de la défense à
l'ouest de paris un quartier d'affaires
certes et depuis 50 ans mais plus
seulement car ce matin jean nouvel
une fois de plus lauréat d'un concours
présentait la tour signal 301 mètres de
haut comme la tour eiffel une sorte de
ville à la verticale
cette tour est à la fois des logements
dans un hôtel de bureau il ya des
commerces
on va voir ce qui se passe dans avoir
tous et logements autour des terrasses
là-haut et des jardins énorme atrium de
l'hôtel elle toute ma vie dedans on l'a
bien compris la défense jusqu'ici
c'était plutôt ceux ci des milliers de
gens affairés qui rentrent chez eux le
soir
loin de leur bureau les promoteurs de la
défense prévoit donc conduit vivent dans
des gratte-ciel d'un nouveau type plus
écologique avec des éoliennes même les
tours devrait donc pousser ici comme
dans le reste de la planète
mais là bas on est sur d'autres échelles
deux fois plus haut et même plus que les
tours de la défense dans le sable de
dubaï 800 mètres cent soixante six
étages le plus haut gratte-ciel du monde
en construction une ville entière là
aussi 512 m ici à taïwan pour cette tour
gigantesque centre commercial ou encore
celle ci en malaisie 452 m en france il
n'est pas question d'aller dans cette
direction
on a décidé de ne pas se lancer dans la
course à la hauteur on a on a d'essayer
se lancer la course à la qualité qu'on
veut quelque chose de beau le bien
intégré ici devrait donc se dresser la
tour signal dans un quartier d'un
nouveau type bien difficile il est vrai
à imaginer l'actualité judiciaire avec
la fin de l'audience au procès fourniret
le jury s'est retiré tout à l'heure pour
délibéré après les plaidoiries et le
verdict est attendu demain l'avocat de
michel fourniret n'a pas requis son
acquittement mais il a appelé les jurés
à faire la part de l'émotion question
comment parvient ton à défendre un homme
qui se juge lui-même indéfendable
reportage sur place amaury guibert bruno
vignais ils sont là tous les soirs et
tous les soirs les insultes fusent
monique olivier et michel fourniret déjà
condamné par la vindicte populaire
deux accusés au profil hors norme
indéfendable diront certains ce matin
les trois avocats commis d'office de
michel fourniret règle est pourtant les
derniers détails de leur plaidoirie
ça aurait été de le défendre contre les
mêmes mais défense aussant d'interdire
d'arrêter une défense a minima comme l'a
exigé l'accusé alors que d'autres
auraient été vus on est commis d'office
au nez commis d'office en reste
simplement on doit me semble-t-il en une
très brève intervention un minimum
d'explications
michel fourniret a droit à une défense
même si on peut dire c'est un monstre
c'est un personnage défense me contre
lui et malgré sa volonté
un accusé qui n'a rien à perdre à tel
point que toutes les attaques se sont
concentrés sur monique olivier une mère
dans le box c'est pire que tout pire
qu'un tueur en série s'insurgera son
avocat bien décidé à défendre sa cliente
sans renier les faits et en respectant
les victimes au nom d'une certaine idée
de la justice
on m'a dit c'est un pro c'est
indéfendable
je suis
j'ai essayé de montrer que défend de
monique olivier c'était possible et que
monique olivier n'avait rien d'un
défendable parce que monique olivier
c'est pas michel fourniret je pense
qu'il ya des différences marquantes
entre les deux mais quels que soient
leur stratégie de défense les accusés
ont fait preuve de la même lucidité
avant même l'ouverture du procès y
disait tous les deux s'attendre à la
peine la plus lourde
la justice encore c'est demain que
s'ouvrira le procès de daniel et gobé
cet homme de 62 ans accusé d'avoir violé
ses deux belles filles alors qu'elle
était enfant et d'avoir prostitué l'une
d'elles au delà la dignité des victimes
la sphère sort de l'ordinaire car les
faits remontent à 20 ans aussi
incroyable que cela puisse paraître
daniel gobeil arrêté à l'époque avait
été laissé en liberté
la justice a été d'une bien étrange
passivité il a donc fallu attendre deux
décennies c'est le dossier de cette
édition il est signée vincent fichman
est thomas donzel
dans les années 80 daniel gober ce rêve
endroits du monde
il est à la tête de cette exploitation
forestière à 50 km au sud de paris
colérique tyrannique il règne sur tout
et sur tout le monde sait le salarié sa
femme et les deux fils de celle-ci
corinne et béatrice en 81 il viole
corinne elle a 9 ans plus tard il la
livrera à ses employés les plus
méritants
il finira par la prostituée elle a 13
ans cela dura trois années tout le
salaire dans cette maison la mère le
savez les ouvriers participer mais
ségolène tout le monde savait qu'il
avait des relations et corinne je pense
est ma vie c'était la prostitution
jamais très longtemps à le comprendre
que c'était autre chose
je pensais qu'un homme s'était que ça
j'avais pas moi comme si j'ai pas connu
les premiers baisers j'ai pas comme ça
on pense que ça même si on ne veut pas
on se dit on n'est bonne qu'à ça
à bout de forces la soeur de corin
finira par s'enfuir et tout raconté
danielle gobert est arrêté et placé en
détention provisoire
l' affaire prend alors un tour
incroyable quelques mois plus tard il
est relâché
officiellement pour raisons de santé
c'est l'obligation être présent à son
procès il ne viendra jamais quand on
remet quelqu'un en liberté il ya des
victimes qu'il ya des faits qui à un
certain nombre de charges dont
l'obligent des pointages à des contrôles
on lui interdit de rencontrer les
victimes de pouvoir faire pression sur
des témoins rien ce genre pour daniel
gobeil alors un soir d'été
il prend la route sa cavale va durer
vingt ans une nouvelle vie donc ce
village de l'indre il habite cette ferme
un peu à l'écart pas de faux papiers
pas plus de planck pour seule règle il
s'emploie à rester discret et à ne
jamais révéler sa véritable identité
il se fait appeler bac du nom de sa
nouvelle compagne pour la première fois
elle parle à notre micro
elle dit n'avoir jamais rien su son
orgueil pour elle cela ne change rien ça
résonne compagnon mais oui mais bien sûr
bien sûr bien sûr y en a qui volent des
pommes c'est pas pour autant qu'on
verrait [ __ ] à la porte un bon s'il
avait été recherché devront
s'enregistrer il ya longtemps que les
gendarmes seraient venus là pour dire
bon bah écoutez madame bac vous avez un
tel qui est chez vous on vient parce
qu'il est recherché
non tout sauf discret dans l'abattoir où
il travaille ses colères deviennent
légendaire et à ceux qui posent trop de
questions
il raconte qu'il est un ancien policier
qui connaît tout le temps narac et ben
quoi pourquoi est elle sera au travail
et 3 et qu'il était policier
comme c'est étrange non pendant ce temps
sans rien soupçonné corinne vive est à
100 km de daniel gobeil elle s'est
reconstruit petit à petit est devenue
serveuse elle a deux enfants et va se
marier à l'automne mais la peur ne l'a
jamais quitté ces vingt années de cavale
ses vingt ans de prison parce qu'on se
retourne toujours dans la rue on a beau
vivre des moments heureux parce qu'on a
envie parce que la vienne est comme ça
mais à des moments voilà c'est une odeur
c'est un bruit c'est une moustache
j'ai eu un passage à vide dans les
années 30 92 et 96 où on se dit c'est
pas vrai ça pas vécu ça m'est pas arrivé
je me fais des films et puis puis j'ai
pété un plomb
j'ai pété un plomb m'enfermer sept
membres 6,4 y y depuis on va dire 96 non
je veux plus oubliée non j'ai eu une
période mais c'est fini puis je veux
surtout pas oublier parce que oublier
c'est lui donner raison
il y à sept mois un contrôle de
gendarmerie va tout stoppé daniel gobert
refuse de donner ses papiers il est
invité à les présenter plus tard il
préférera se rendre dans un commissariat
parisien
vingt années de cavale mais la justice
n'a rien oublié cette fois il va être
jugé
josef strauss et j'y serai et et voilà
je le veux et je mais il ya une part de
moi qui ai dit qu il ya vingt ans de
retard
comment daniel gober at il pu
disparaître si facilement le procès qui
s'ouvre demain sera aussi celui de sa
cavale l'actualité à l'étranger naples a
n'en a pas fini avec le problème des
ordures silvio berlusconi a sur place
avait annoncé l'ouverture de nouvelles
décharges mais les élus locaux et une
partie de la population des quartiers
concernés ou des communes avoisinantes
sur pause coûte que coûte envoyés
spéciaux philippe visseyrias karine dit
ce soir les rues de kaya ne ressemble
encore un champ de bataille des arbres
abattus en travers de la route des
guetteurs à moto des barricades tous les
100 mètres
ici dans cette banlieue pauvre du nord
de naples la police ne rentre pas le
quartier appartient aux habitants en
colère qui se relayent jour et nuit
toute génération confondue pour en
interdire l'accès nous un petit groupe
de citoyens nous sommes devenus les
ennemis de l'état italien
on dit même qu'ils pourraient nous
envoyer l'armée si on continue comme tel
molotov et blocs de ciment contre coups
de matraque
ces derniers jours qu'ils aillent and on
a vécu un climat de guerre civile après
avoir tenté de prendre possession du
quartier la police a même dû faire
marche arrière
à l'origine de ces affrontements la
décision du gouvernement de silvio
berlusconi de choisir ses carrières
désaffectées à quelques centaines de
mètres à peine des premières habitations
pour y créer la plus grande décharge à
ciel ouvert de la région moi je
travaille ici dans cette histoire je
vais perdre trois choses les ruiner ma
santé ma maison ne vaudra plus rien et
je vais perdre mon travail et qu'est ce
que je vais gagner en échange
en signe d'apaisement les manifestants
ont accepté ce matin de laisser
travailler les techniciens chargés
d'étudier les sols de la carrière leurs
analyses seront connus dans 20 jours en
attendant autour des barrages des tas
d'ordures chacun campe sur ses positions
les riverains déterminée et la police
discrète pour le gouvernement la
bataille de kayhan est devenu un symbole
s'il cède ici
il aura bien du mal à imposer son
autorité sur les neuf autres sites qui
ont été sélectionnés pour y installer
des décharges en chine nouvelle frayeur
deux semaines après le séisme deux
répliques ont semé la panique des
centaines des milliers de maisons se
sont effondrées soixante trois personnes
ont été blessées
claude sans père une nouvelle réplique
vient de se produire dans le sud ouest
de la chine
de nouveau la population qui descend
trouvé refuge dans la rue
au loin des pan de montagne qui
s'effondre selon les autorités plus de
420 mille maisons ont été détruites
quinze jours après le grand tremblement
de terre des milliers de soldats restent
mobilisés aujourd'hui
leurs efforts étaient surtout
concentrées autour d'un grand lac dans
les montagnes une immense réserve d'eau
qui pourrait engloutir des centaines de
milliers de personnes
il ya quinze jours une partie de la
montagne s'est écroulé dans la vallée et
créant un barrage naturel et celui ci
menace de céder alors les militaires ont
décidé d'apporter par hélicoptère
plusieurs dizaines de bulldozer
un travail de titan sous le barrage vit
une population d'un million trois cent
mille personnes
l'objectif des militaires creusé une
brèche dans le barrage un travail à haut
risque à tout moment le barrage peut
céder entièrement et tout emporté en fin
de journée après des heures d'efforts
ils ont réussi une première percée et
l'eau a pu commencer à s'échapper
une belle victoire pour ses hommes
aujourd'hui mais autorités ont annoncé
le dernier bilan
plus de 88 mille morts et disparus et à
noter par ailleurs qu'à deux mois et
demi des jeux olympiques pékin a
enregistré aujourd'hui un pic de
pollution en raison de tempêtes de sable
qui balaient la mangue ou relais la
mongolie il est conseillé aux habitants
les plus fragiles de ne pas sortir de
chez eux
vladimir poutine à paris c'est à la
france qu'il réserve son premier grand
déplacement en tant que chef du
gouvernement et non plus de président il
arrivera après demain la russie est
devenue un partenaire de premier plan
politiquement et économiquement avec la
chine et l'inde elle fait désormais
partie de ce que l'on appelle les pays
émergents au taux de croissance record
on a vu ainsi apparaître une nouvelle
classe moyenne supérieure russe à fort
pouvoir d'achat sur place à moscou nous
rend boussier xavier l'usaid qui elena
francs sa voiture le matin c'est
évidemment pour amener ses filles à
l'école mais surtout pour aller faire
ses courses dans les grands centres
commerciaux qui fleuriste à la
périphérie de moscou
on a comparé les prix font deux fois
moins cher que dans les magasins du
centre village c'est très bien pour eux
des familiales on a beau faire partie de
la nouvelle classe moyenne russe dans la
ville la plus chère du monde il faut
savoir compter et puis dans ces grandes
surfaces et les nac comme tous les
consommateurs russes mesure le chemin
parcouru l'asie revenu familial 3000
euros par mois deux voitures de marques
étrangères dont une achetée à crédit un
appartement rénové dans un quartier
agréable de moscou et pour le père un
travail dans l'édition les loginov font
partie de cette classe moyenne russe
apparu pendant les années poutine
les prix élevés du pétrole et
l'augmentation des salaires il n'y a
qu'une certaine stabilité et une
relative confiance en l'avenir 10 à 15%
de la population vu une terrible envie
de consommer est un must
les vacances à l'étranger il n'y a qu'à
voir le plaisir avec lequel natacha
elena racontent leurs multiples séjours
en lituanie là ce sont les dunes du
lualaba et la mer la synchro tél toutes
les maisons sont aussi petit
on aime beaucoup aller là bas parce que
c'est très beau peu intéressé par la
politique sans illusion sur les
manquements à la démocratie fait classe
moyenne russe souhaite avant tout
profiter comme les autres de la
mondialisation direction l'himalaya
maintenant avec les conséquences du
changement climatique est une opération
gigantesque qui est sans doute une
première pour compenser le recul des
glaces et donc de l'alimentation en eau
de toute une région
des scientifiques se met pas créer des
glaciers artificielle envoyés spéciaux
arnauld miguet dominique marault tél vu
du ciel
rien d'anormal pourtant ces neiges de
l'himalaya fondent à vue d'oeil
nous sommes au ladakh le petit tibet
région difficile d'accès point c'est
entre la chine et le pakistan
les sa capitale est à plus de 3500
mètres d'altitude
ces habitants de tradition bouddhiste
l'ift essentiellement de l'agriculture
et si l'oxygène manque aux visiteurs les
lada qui eux souffrent cruellement d'une
pénurie d'eau car l'eau des glaciers se
raréfient et désert d'altitude des
fields à perte de vue
tu one norphel à 73 ans est ingénieur à
la retraite enfant du pays constate les
dégâts
regardez-vous là le résultat du
réchauffement climatique
normalement à cette saison il aimerait
pierre ici il ya beaucoup d'eau il
faudra monter à plus de 5000 mètres au
pays des yacks et des premières neiges
pour comprendre que ces glaciers de
l'himalaya sont en voie de disparition
il reculerait de 10 à 15 m par an ici
autrefois nous étions entourés de
glaciers naturel à cause de leur
disparition les gens de la vallée doit
faire face à une grande pénurie d'eau
alors monsieur nord feld a décidé d'agir
avec une idée toute simple et peu
coûteuse vous voyez c'est ce genre de
murs que nous construisons en séries ils
permettent de retenir la neige qui se
transforme en glace plus de glaciers
naturel qu'à cela ne tienne voici le
premier glaciaire artificielle au monde
quelques digues de pierres qui
retiennent la neige et le tour est joué
encore fallait-il trouver le bon
emplacement ce premier glacier il y en a
sept aujourd'hui
il en parle comme d'un enfant qui a
grandi 300 mètres de long sur 60 de
l'argent 87
il s'est en vingt ans plus tard sur plus
de deux kilomètres
et voici le résultat
au premier jour du printemps l'eau du
glacier artificielle descend vers les
vallées et permet d'arroser ses champs
de paysans en pleine saison de semences
ici dans ce village de bouc cfoot si on
fait de l'orge des pommes de terre et
des navets aujourd'hui on peut tirer le
champ au moins deux fois plus longtemps
pour ses lada qui monsieur norphel qu'on
appelle ici l'homme des glaces est un
homme providentiel son invention a
permis à quatre villages et 1500
personnes de continuer à cultiver leurs
terres
heureusement qu'il est là il neige
beaucoup moins qu'avant et dans beaucoup
d'endroits il n'y a plus que des
cailloux de quoi garder le sourire
même si cette généreuse fontaine que fut
l'himalaya se tarit quatre cinquièmes
des glaciers naturel pourraient
disparaître d'ici 40 ans retour en
france avec une nouvelle sanction contre
les fumeurs de cannabis pris en flagrant
délit beaucoup s'accordaient à dire que
la répression n'avait pas grand sens
d'ailleurs elle était peu pratique et
rappelant plan contre 4 millions de
fumeurs occasionnels et bien il s'agit
cette fois d'une sanction pédagogique en
quelque sorte un stage de
sensibilisation aux dangers du cannabis
le premier du genre s'est ouvert hier à
dijon sur place josé blanc lapierre
juillet à moi aujourd'hui
deux jours pour se racheter prendre
conscience que le cannabis n'est pas
anodin qu à force on petit perdre sa
santé son boulot sa famille un stage
punition pour des jeunes prise en
flagrant délit au volant devant un
établissement scolaire ou encore lors
d'un trafic à la frontière le message
fort de ces stages chez leur faire
comprendre que la consommation de
stupéfiants pour le problème dans la vie
et que l'orage même s'il ne vaille pas
directement ça amène probablement une
perte de liberté une perte de
compréhension de lui face à la justice
ces jeunes ont eu le choix
c'est la première fois soit être jugé
soit participer à ce stage moyennant 230
euros et pas forcément pour subir une
leçon de morale quand on a vu ici on
contexte est répressif on allait venir
dans un endroit où on nouvelle c'est pas
bien il faut pas faire s'il faut pas
faire ça alors qu'on nous dit pas il
faut pas faire si trois personnes mais
il faut faire attention comme on fait du
cannabis des barrettes que les chiens de
la brigade des stupéfiants de dijon
après tard unifiée démonstration et
rappelle qu'il était temps d'agir face
aux cent mille interpellations par an je
crois que ces avertissements sont allés
au bout de leurs limites en termes
d'efficacité puisque la consommation
continue à augmenter dans notre pays
l'héroïne
1 et que le cannabis est un grand niveau
de consommation des stages donc pour
lutter contre le cannabis qui a pris
aujourd'hui autant d'importance que le
tabac le tennis avant d'en venir aux
résultats de la journée à roland garros
gros plan sur les bébés champions les
futurs professionnels sont repérés de
plus en plus tôt parfois quatre ou cinq
ans aux filières traditionnelles
s'ajoute en effet des académies privé
enquête julien benedetto vincent barral
elle est russe elle n'a que 16 ans c'est
la plus jeune joueuse du tournoi
voici à l'entraînement la dernière
recrue de patrick mouratoglou directeur
d'une académie trevi de tennis près
paribas dénicheur de talents entraîneur
au verbe atypique de l'énergie dans les
jambes de l'énergie dans le haut du
corps
laisse ton corps s'exprimer 6-1 6-1 en
45 minutes
la voilà au deuxième tour patrick
mouratoglou en est persuadé il cerne
future championne le plus jeune joueur
de son académie c'est lui yann silva 6
ans déjà une star dans les allées de
roland garros ce petit américain coûte
très cher à l'académie cent mille euros
par an lui et sa famille sont
entièrement prises en charge nourriture
logement matériel entraîneur un contrat
de dix ans un investissement sur du long
terme
si je réussis à me rembourse le coût de
sa formation il me rends et il me donne
un pourcentage sur ses liens qui me
permets moi de générer un peu d'argent
qui profitera au projet d'un autre
enfant et puis si réussis pas c'est
l'argent que j'avais si je les ai perdus
alors les centres d'entraînement privé
sont ils l'avenir du tennis
nous sommes sur les installations
ultramodernes du groupe lagardère ici
pas d'enfants mais des joueurs
professionnels qui bénéficient de
conditions d'entraînement high tech
gasquet mathieu et monfils ont été
séduits
le mécénat version moderne
l'introduction d'un bond des privés
c'est forcément un plus quand je vois un
petit peu ce qui se passe en espagne
quand je vois ce qui se passe aux etats
unis
dans la plupart des joueurs sortent de
ces académies
si les structures privées attire de plus
en plus les parents d'apprentis
champions alors la fédération réagit et
fait une entorse à son modèle de sport
études
kristina mladenovic jeune française de
15 ans considéré comme la future
mauresmo bénéficie des services d'un
entraîneur rien que pour elle presque
une révolution à la fédération on est
capable d'offrir à la fédération
aujourd'hui une structure personnalisé
qui correspondent au niveau exceptionnel
d'une joueuse de 12 ans d'une joueuse de
14 ans ou d'un joueur de 16 ans détectée
par la fédération ou couvait dans une
structure privée comme le petit âne
ils sont une centaine en france à rêver
des peurs noix du grand chelem seuls
quelques-uns réussirons à atteindre cet
objectif
et ils prendront peut-être exemple sur
amélie mauresmo diminué par une blessure
aux côtes la française s'est tout de
même qualifié mais difficilement pour le
deuxième tour à la battu l'ukrainienne
olga savchuk 81e mondial en trois sets 6
1 au dernier set
voici la balle de match
à noter chez les hommes la victoire de
davydenko numéro 4 mondial très peu de
matchs sont déroulées aujourd'hui encore
en raison de la pluie vous les avez
suivi en direct sur france 2 ou france 3
ou france 4
en bref à propos de sports charles
villeneuve a été officiellement nommé
président du paris saint germain
le journaliste âgé de 67 ans entame donc
une nouvelle carrière
si vous regardez la télévision vous la
connaissez forcément après la série
culte sex and the city voici le film les
quatre jeunes new yorkaise débarque sur
grand écran avec une comédie qui n'a
rien perdu de sa liberté de ton emmanuel
lambert
carrie samantha charlotte et miranda
sont de retour après six saisons dans la
petite lucarne
les copines new yorkaises débarque au
cinéma - elles sont contentes mais la
révélation c'est que carrie jouée par
sarah jessica parker va enfin se marier
s'installer avec mister big l'homme de
sa vie qu'il ferait cette zone reste des
travaux dans la cuisine j'y connais rien
moi je range mes pulls dans le phare
dont il va l'acheter
tu vas y vivre avec mini c'est
miraculeux manquait tellement lors du
tournage des centaines de fans ont tenté
d'approcher les actrices car sex and the
city est un phénomène 94 épisodes
traduit dans toutes les langues
l'amour shopping et l'histoire d'amour
cru voilà pour les ingrédients
principaux
et que les inconditionnels se rassurent
si l'amour est très présent les filles
parlent toujours autant de sets
vous faites l'amour tous les combien
j'ai 41 ans et moi non plus je ne sais
toujours pas un peu l'ouvrier il faut
juste choisir des poids moyens très bien
combien de fois vous faites dès que la
riaj merci même s'ils ont une culture
différente que leur histoire ne sont pas
les mêmes on va voir les femmes sont
accrochés grâce à cette lettre d'amour
universel autres cultures voiture
parfums bijoux au total 163 marques
apparaissent dans le film
parfois c'est un peu stressant surtout
quand la pub dure plus de deux heures
d'un et surtout quand ça continue en
interview j'ai produit saint-laurent
school ces français oui j'aime la france
nous sommes honorés première à porte
pour vous les filles trouveront elles
enfin l'amour une chose est sûre si la
série a pris quelques rides
le film élégant est plutôt réussie donne
un coup de jeune voir une piqûre de
botox aux quatre héroïnes et puis on a
appris la mort de l'acteur réalisateur
et producteur sydney pollack s'est tenue
à los angeles
il était l un des cinéastes américains
contemporains les plus prolixes vous
vous souvenez sans doute de tutsis ou
encore de hauteur of africa le film aux
sept oscars sydney pollack avait 73 et
ce avant de refermer cette édition je
vous en rappelle l'un des principaux
titres
les grèves et les manifestations
s'amplifient dans le monde contre la
flambée du pétrole camionneurs à londres
étudiant en indonésie pêcheurs à madrid
des pêcheurs qui durcissent aussi encore
le mouvement en france de nombreux corps
restent bloqués des ambulanciers et des
agriculteurs ont également manifesté
contre le prix des carburants c'est la
fin de ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi
tout de suite la météo laurent romejko
20h50 le bal des célibataires un
téléfilm avec notamment cristiana reali
à demain
l'info en continu
c'est aussi sur france 2 point fr